welcome thank you so much for joining us
for aid geopolitics and power our human
rights back
on the international aid agenda this is
the fifth in a series the yale
development dialogues economic policy
lessons from history
which is co-hosted by the yale economic
growth center the south asian studies
council from the yale mcmillan center
and the jackson institute for global
affairs i'm catherine chaney and i'll be
your moderator today
i'll briefly introduce the topic and our
panelists before we dive in
but as i always reiterate these events
are designed to be conversational
and we really value your questions so if
you're joining us on zoom
please keep your questions coming
throughout in the q a and we'll get to
them as soon as we can
so this topic is such a great fit for
our approach in this series
bringing historians and practitioners
together when higher income countries
get involved in lower income countries
whether through foreign aid
disaster relief or military intervention
they can justify their acts by the goals
to reduce poverty protect human rights
or advance their own interests
and part of why we're having this
conversation today is due to some recent
structural changes
at major international development
agencies here in the u.s
as well as in the uk marking shift in
priorities
so yesterday was samantha powers
confirmation hearing as president joe
biden's pick for administrator for the
u.s agency for international development
and as many of you know the uk's
department for international development
merged with the foreign commonwealth
office uniting development and diplomacy
in one new department
the foreign commonwealth and development
office or fcdo
so usaid and fcdo two acronyms you'll be
hearing about a lot today
as some of the shifts we're seeing and
we'll talk about what lessons history
might offer
what lessons might history offer as
these agencies change their structure in
pursuit of new priorities
our panelists are going to look at
foreign interventions of the past
their stated intentions and real world
effects and they'll ask what this
renewed emphasis on human rights
might mean for poverty reduction in a
world of extreme inequality
so joining us to discuss these topics
i'd like to introduce melissa dell
she's a professor of economics at
harvard university her work focuses on
long-run economic development primarily
in latin america and asia
and she's conducted research on how u.s
military strategies in vietnam
had a lasting impact on that country's
institutions you'll hear
more about that and some of her other
research today samuel moyne is henry
arluz professor of jurisprudence at yale
law school and professor of history at
yale university
and author of not enough human rights in
an unequal world
very relevant to today's discussion his
areas of interest in legal scholarship
include international law human rights
the law of war and legal thought in both
historical and current perspective
and two familiar names for those of you
for those of you who have joined us
before
uh rohini panda is the henry j heinz the
second professor of economics and
director of the economic growth center
at yale her research is largely focused
on how
formal and informal institutions shape
power relationships
and patterns of economic and political
advantage in society
particularly in developing countries and
rory stewart is a senior fellow at the
yale jackson institute for global
affairs
where he focuses on contemporary
politics in crisis
and on international development and
intervention in fragile and conflict
conflict-affected states and rory also
served as the uk secretary of state
for international development diffid
which i mentioned earlier
where he doubled the uk's investment in
international climate and environment
so i'd like to start uh with rohini
actually because
rohini was really the person who put
this on the agenda
for our yell development dialogues is
something to discuss something where
history may offer lessons for today so
rohini can you expand on some of the
trends you're seeing in foreign aid
development policy and governance in the
21st century particularly in a low
middle income country context
and what does this demand or why does
this demand this question we're asking
today
are human rights back on the
international aid agenda
thanks catherine and thanks everyone for
joining
so let me just step back a couple of
decades to the start of the 21st century
which i think was a very heady time for
international development
economic growth in many parts of asia
were fast reducing
poverty and coming on the heels of the
jubilee 2000 debt relief
rich countries were typically expanding
their aid programs
so much so that according to one
brookings estimate by 2006 the amount of
foreign aid available in the world
was sufficient to bring every extreme
poor person up to the threshold of 1.90
a day
and alongside on the research side in
development economics we saw a growing
interest
in quantifying the impact of development
policies and this was exemplified by the
rise of the experimental analysis of
development projects
but while that research has flourished
and was exemplified by the nobel prize
in 2019 to ban energy do flow and
creamer
i think the politics of aids started
taking a different turn
in the second decade of the 21st century
so in 2013 both canada and australia
merged their aid departments with their
foreign offices
and then catherine as you mentioned uh
in june of last year
boris johnson announced the merger of
the
foreign commonwealth office with the
department of international development
to create what they described as a new
super department the foreign
commonwealth and development office
and most recently uh samantha parr has
been formally given a table
at the national security council
recognizing that the mission of u.s aid
alongside defense and diplomacy is
contributing to national security
and a common narrative which actually
goes back to what albert said
as australian uh head at the time of the
merger
was i quote we are going to bring aid
back inside the department because we
want australia's aid program to be fully
integrated into our overall diplomatic
effort
we don't want our diplomacy going in one
direction and our aid program going
another
and so what we see today is that rich
countries are increasingly explicit
about a desire to leverage foreign aid
for domestic goals
and i think this raises this question of
what happens to the world's poor and
vulnerable
and so this brings us today to the start
of the third decade of the 21st century
which i see is marked by two forces
first we're entering a decade
where perhaps because of austerity
policies in rich countries because of
growing inequality
rich countries are extremely willing to
see development quite explicitly as a
situation of power
one where they're going to use their
resources and the geopolitical might
to by leverage but importantly we're
also entering a decade of democratic
backsliding in many parts of the world
so we are seeing cases of elected rulers
you know weakening checks on executive
part curtailing political and civil
liberties and undermining the integrity
of the electoral system
very often in i'd say lower and higher
middle income countries
and this is what really brings me to
this idea that i think we need to
revisit the implications
of putting human rights on the table to
date very few
aid agencies have led with it but as we
see growing inequality
uh which makes it harder than for them
to roll out just cash transfers to
the poor and as we see democratic
backsliding
we want i think it's important to ask
what the challenges are in putting human
rights as being central
to development agenda and let me just
say what i see is the challenge for
development economists
um of which i am one i think that the
challenge is that over the last two
decades we've seen a lot of push on
testing programs in the social sector of
saying we want to put resources
uh where uh we can test it but how do
you do how do you actually identify
how can you help liberal democracies in
the developing world
you know what institutions can we
support how do we actually test
whether that works and then you know how
do we persuade
which countries to put money there for
instance one example when i think we do
have evidence
is on independent and credible media
we have a lot of evidence from actually
field experiments suggesting that they
help with accountability
but to me the open question is how is
this actually going to become part
of what aid agencies do so over to
catherine
with that thank you rohini and
you set us up well by talking about how
rising inequality may demand some change
may put
human rights back on the table even if
agencies haven't
led with it and that brings me to a
question for sam
so sam in your book you explore why the
rise of human rights over time has not
actually resulted
in social and economic justice but
instead happened alongside growing
inequality as rohini described so can
you expand on that disconnect for us
sure to begin with thanks for the
invitation and thanks for having me
um i look forward to learning a lot you
know
uh i'm i i would have said that
starting in the 40s uh the human rights
agenda and the development agenda have
been pretty disconnected and remain so
to this day it's it's really
never the tween shall meet rather than
the the idea that
human rights were connected to
development and are now being
put back uh in in the 1940s there was
the universal declaration of human
rights which came
along with some basic standards in the
economic realm which
we call economic and social rights harry
truman
in my country uh announced point four
which is conventionally dated as the
kind of origin of of development
assistance the trouble is
that uh that that the the ideologies of
development have
you know uh waxed and waned according to
different
orthodoxies uh amongst economists
and have been pretty tightly linked to
national security agendas of giving
states and that
is likely to remain true for as long as
we can imagine
and as far as i can tell there there
really hasn't been
much connection even once human rights
began to be taken more seriously by the
united states and
the united kingdom as foreign policy uh
aspirations in the 1970s
there are a couple of sec of exceptions
to that generalization there was
conditionality
um uh saying that foreign aid had to be
kind of
used as a a carrot uh to
in incentivize bad regimes to treat
their
their peoples less badly there was also
some
uh some intersection between jimmy
carter
that president who kind of brought human
rights to the global stage
and his development um people who began
to talk a lot about
about basic needs um you know to come to
your question
you know my own you know thesis has been
that human rights
um name a kind of sufficiency idea
the the basic entitlements in that
every human should get on on the basis
of his
her their humanity you know housing
food health that that is not the same as
a campaign against global poverty
although it's true
that the campaign against global poverty
of the last 40 or 50 years has also been
about a very a floor of
of sufficient provision it's much lower
let's be honest a dollar
and change a day the world bank standard
of extreme poverty that rohini
mentioned is is not the schedule
of economic and social rights more to
the point
human rights activists even once they
began
taking economic and social rights more
seriously alongside free speech and
for bodily integrity and things like
that um
have been have been persistently
critical of development theory
for neglecting the much higher floor
of protection that human rights are
supposed to promise
um as of today i would say
there's there's i i wouldn't think aside
from samantha powers
appointment and elevation uh
that there's there's a lot of prospect
for human rights coming to development i
mean that could be a rhetoric
what it means um
is is hard to say and not only power is
not even on the usaid
website yet um for one thing
um the the the eradication of poverty
has most
most most mostly not worked through
any kind of human rights agenda to date
and it's been very spotty highly
localized
in on on the surface of the world we've
just lived through a pandemic
you know we're in the final stages of it
hopefully at least in the global north
which has seen a lot of reversals um
in the anti-poverty agenda i would
um close by saying though power is there
the the stated foreign policy agenda of
joe biden and his people
is actually to care most about the
american middle class and you see that
i think most graphically in a march 2
speech that new secretary of state
anthony blinken
gave in which he says that every little
bit of the reorientation of
american foreign policy which must
include what samantha power is going to
be doing
is really focused on making sure
that policymakers don't forget
northern working classes uh which led to
donald trump
you know many think uh and so
the the let's make sure not to you know
um get get fooled by the hype
that were on the brink of vast changes
do you want to close with that all right
we'll make sure not to get to get into
the hype or at least we'll break down
whether this is rhetoric or whether this
is real and i
i i uh took note of something sam said
which i think
um really captures one of the themes
we're getting at here
um that a floor of sufficient provision
does not equal
social and economic rights and that
development theory tends to neglect the
much higher floor
of protecting uh that human rights are
meant to promise
and um so we'll see we'll see if there's
change but
um sam seems uh unconvinced that we're
on the brink of major change and
um i think that's great we're going to
get into perhaps some debate among our
panelists a bit later
but i want to go ahead and bring melissa
into this conversation
melissa your research has focused on how
foreign intervention
affects development across the range of
geographies and i'd love for you to
expand on some of your research
in vietnam those who may have seen the
promotional video for this webinar might
have a preview of that
your research in vietnam as well as
mexico and what lessons
from those experiences seem most urgent
and relevant today
thank you so much and thank you um also
uh
for uh for inviting me to be here
so i want to start by picking up on a
point that came up before when rohini
was talking which is this idea that
we've seen
in recent years kind of geopolitical
objectives
and development objectives moving closer
together and becoming more intertwined
um and i'd say that if anything like
that's
been the norm and maybe you know like in
the period after the cold war
um you know uh people were a bit less
anxious about those
geopolitical objectives and that relaxed
a bit but i think that that's changing
now and kind of with the rise of china
and that it's not an accident that this
is happening again and so if you go back
um and you think about the policies in
the uh 1960s with
john f kennedy the alliance for progress
you know his other kind of
development aid priorities those were
very closely linked
to the fight against communism into the
cold war and i think that that's
just the norm um and you know to tie
this back in
to the the question and to my research
um and
you know so broadly speaking we can
think about kind of two different
schools of thought about how
the us and other rich countries kind of
achieve their geopolitical objectives
um in low-income countries um and
so again if we go back to the cold war
there was this very kind of prominent
view
um popularized uh the most by like walt
rostow who was an economist and also
lyndon johnson's national security
advisor
um that you know communism is this
disease
of the transition from being an
agricultural to an industrialized
society
um and um you know uh
the us needed to to stop um poor
countries from sakomin um you know to
that disease and there were two general
ways to do it
um and so what rostow and what others
advocated for
is you do that through force um you make
people realize that it's gonna be
extremely
costly um if they go against
um you know the non-communist state in
the context of the cold war
and the other view which was actually
much less sort of
prominent historically but some people
did argue for it is that you have to
give
people uh meaningful incentives um
you know to support a democracy or to
support a non-communist state
um through you know through the state
providing them things that are
meaningful to their lives you know
schools health clinics
um security um things like that
um and so this is a question that i
studied in the context of
the vietnam war where the objective of
the us and the vietnam war wasn't so
much
you know stamping out specific
insurgents per se but it was
creating a south vietnamese state that
would stand
as a bulwark against communism after the
us withdrew
and to have that people have to support
the state um and so they're
very explicitly kind of social
scientists economists political
scientists etc they thought about like
well how do you get people
on to to support the state and sort of
the
dominant view and what the u.s
overwhelmingly pursued was to do that
through overwhelming firepower
you make it extremely costly um
for them to go against the state um and
i think like very much
game theory was influential kind of in
how people thought about this
um and just kind of the general
intuition that if you go out and you'd
be really aggressive
that they're gonna back down and so you
know the us
dropped many times more bombs on south
vietnam than were dropped
in all of asia and all of europe and
world war ii just an overwhelming amount
of firepower
um and in our paper we're able to
exploit exogenous variation from
an algorithm that the us used to target
these bombings to show that that policy
backfired
um that when they bombed civilian areas
um that rather than people saying oh
like i better do what the u.s wants and
what
the south vietnamese government wants i
better support the state and said they
wouldn't join the viet cong because they
were angry
um you know rightfully uh so um
but that wasn't like you know that um
that wasn't the only thing the us did in
vietnam that was the dominant
perspective um but um
an interesting context that we also look
at is that the us
marines by and large took a different
kind of perspective
um on fighting the war and so the us
marines have this sort of
long history of being like the us
imperial police force so to say like in
the caribbean
um and you know i'm sure that they did
lots of horrible human rights abuses
there
um but compare that to the army who's
kind of um you know founding motives
were just to line up
and shoot as many people as possible
it's like a different perspective they
worked a lot more closely with locals
they did development aid
and that's what they pushed in vietnam
um and so we look at this area that was
commanded by the marines
versus very nearby places that were
commanded by the army
the marines built schools they built
health clinics um
they work closely with locals and in
those areas you see far yet
you know less attacks on the us um you
see people are south vietnamese citizens
and public opinion data are more
supportive of all levels of south
vietnamese government
um you know and and on the us they
actually
see public goods actually being provided
you know so obviously we can't say
well would it have been better if the us
just didn't get into this conflict at
all you know which there's a strong
argument for but like conditional
kind of on being there and finding this
conflict this kind of development aid
approach appears to be
um much more effective um and then kind
of to tie this idea into the present i
don't think that this is something that
is
you know limited to the cold war um that
is limited to foreign intervention per
se
there's just this broad idea of like you
have places that are not really um
within the control of the state um and
this is very common
like how do you bring those places you
know under the control
of a state and this was also like what i
looked at
in mexico um at the war on drugs in
mexico
and so this is not exactly foreign
intervention although obviously foreign
policy is a big motivator for the war on
drugs and that has had kind of
that's another kind of rich country
policy that has had enormous
implications on for the developing world
um but i look there at you know
crackdowns on the drug trade
and show something that's you know a
little bit reminiscent of
what we found in vietnam which is that
um
the state comes in they crack down on
the drug trade in a given location
um and that weakens the incumbent and
leads you know their rivals to come in
and try to fight and since the state
actually has fairly limited capacity it
just unleashes these drug wars
and then people just take the drugs
around um and so
you know it's not as if um you know this
is i think the goal of mexico was to get
the drugs to like go through the
caribbean
um but in the end that didn't happen
they just took other rats in mexico and
it kind of unleashed this violence
um and you know of course the state side
of it is not the only side we also show
that
when young men lose their jobs due to
trade shocks from china they're also
more likely to go join drug gangs and
that creates violence and so there's an
economic component as well
but in general i think that it's kind of
reminiscent of the same debates that
came up
in the 60s and 70s you know so i was
talking with um you know some
officials in mexico and there was a
group
like an influential group that was
really heavily advocating like okay
let's not just fight this
on through sending in the military like
let's give
development aid we know in some of these
places there's not other job
opportunities people don't trust the
state
um because they've had a bad experience
maybe the state can come in and build
infrastructure and that's useful for
creating jobs
um and you know they almost got that
programming off they almost got that
program off the ground but then somebody
else came in and was like
wait a minute like we're national
security like we don't do development
aid that's for the social development
ministry like what do you mean like we
go in and we show them who's in charge
um and i think you know to to tie it
back into the beginning and think about
kind of the most
pressing lessons you know at least you
know i'm not an expert on international
diplomacy
um but people would argue that we're
kind of moving into this phase of kind
of um
you know a new cold war or something
like it with china where china is rising
you know they're taking kind of a very
aggressive stance on the global stage
and you know
how's that going to play out um and
and it kind of um linking on
this idea of like development aid with
diplomacy like the reality is that
diplomacy is just always going to be
you know that like um and like the the
security interests
are gonna be like the number one
objective um but is there a way to do
that where
you know even if it's like grossly
inadequate development aid that's you
know getting people's income up a few
cents or something that's better than
going
and like um you know um dropping bombs
on them
or you know encouraging you know a
government to take on like a violent
conflict against people right and so
um i think that it is actually
a potentially promising thing that these
objectives kind of get integrated and
how do we think about you know our
influence on the global stage not just
through
being the kind of aggressive the most
aggressive you know
country around um but also giving people
um
you know in incentives um to
to to want to support the us or to want
to support you know
on our objectives on through
through development aid and other
policies thanks melissa really helpful
examples in terms of
uh when we look at this connection
between development and diplomacy and
defense
uh how has it worked to use incentives
versus force over time and i'm glad you
mentioned china
um i hope that's uh something we can
return to when we all uh jump into
discussion in a little bit
and we have some great questions coming
in so just a reminder to those of us uh
those of you joining us on zoom
please keep those questions coming i'm
excited to get to some of these but i
want to bring rory into this uh so rory
we mentioned earlier
some of the changes happening with um
foreign aid in the uk uh that aid agenda
has undergone
quite a transformation over the past
year and is still changing it seems
so i'd like to ask you what does this
mean for the uk's work on human rights
and how has that changed as a priority
from when
you led diffid to now and what do you
expect next
aurora you're on mute first thing
first thing to understand is that we are
um
going through in the
uk what is a pretty natural evolution i
guess
for every country and has some
implications the u.s which is that
diffid was set up with a very idealistic
structure
so in the late 1990s the idea was that
the uk would commit to spend
0.7 percent of its gdp on international
development
and it would create this completely
independent department of government
cabinet level department which would
have basically nothing to do with the
foreign service
or the ministry of defense and it was
set up by law that it could only spend
money in order to tackle extreme poverty
and this was deliberately done because
obviously the people working
for it and setting it up wanted to try
to protect it
against any of the other temptations so
it was almost the purest possible kind
of
incarnation of a dream of development
um it was also set up so that there
could not be
any confusions with national interests
that were very very
legal actions to stop
people using this money to try to
procure british goods or do anything of
this sort
from the beginning this was an enormous
problem
and a problem that the people working
for diffid probably did not fully
anticipate or understand
they staffed the department with many
many people who were development
autonomous
or came out of ngos
and they at some level
people were very very reluctant to get
involved in the conversation with the
public
or other politicians about what this
money was being used
to do and the scale of money you're
talking to so by the time i was running
different we had a budget of about 20
billion us dollars a year
totally unrestricted right i had no
control at all about really how that
money was spent
because it was almost impossible for any
other government department to get its
hand on that money
in addition austerity was taking place
so i remember this extraordinary meeting
that i had with rohini when i just be
moved from my i think my second place to
differed
i'd been moved to run uk prisons before
i went back to different again
and i moved from this enormous office
that i had in different this tiny little
uh place in a concrete building setting
was rahini that morning i'd signed off
on i think something like 200 million
dollars for
an education program in ethiopia
and that afternoon i'm sitting with
rohini now as the minister for prisons
realizing that we were going to have to
get rid of the bottom
five floors of our office in central
london in order to try to save i think
nine or 10 million
pounds having just signed off on 200
million that morning
and this of course meant that enormous
problems were then raised about what on
earth was happening with this money
right when the public began looking at
it
and you can think of all the kind of
problems because we experienced them and
of course
this is relevant for joe biden this is
relevant to jake sullivan this is
relevant for samantha power because of
course what jake sullivan has been
writing about a great deal
is the sense in which u.s foreign policy
cannot be detached from what people
us citizens think i mean it's been
for 60 70 years really an elite
occupation
people have tried to remove foreign
policy away
from public opinion but
in the end you have to justify it you
have to answer basic questions right
so you say that you're eliminating
global poverty how are you doing you
know what have you been doing over the
last 40 years where are your success
stories
you are working with this regime so
let's just run through some of the
problems in britain and then i'll just
flip it back to human rights right what
were the practical problems
we were giving a hundred million pounds
a year to india
why because india had a lot of poor
people
but we then discovered that india was
giving exactly a hundred million pounds
a year in development aid to afghanistan
right so the british public is being
asked to give 100 million pounds
a year to india and india is just giving
all that money to afghanistan right
well from the point of view of diffid
employees
there was no problem with this because
there were people living in extreme
poverty in northern india so they
couldn't see why anybody
found the surprise or i would go in to
see
president kagame in rwanda and i would
talk about human rights a big human
rights problems in rwanda and he would
laugh
and say you don't care about human
rights and i'd say what do you mean i
don't care about human rights and he'd
say
quite explicitly in this meeting well
you've just given us
another 100 million pounds of
development aid so if you cared about
human rights you wouldn't do that would
you
so these conversations are happening all
the time that's before you get on to the
things that you can imagine
scandals about corruption scandals about
waste huge anxieties in britain which
haven't yet hit the united states but i
promise you they're coming
about the amount of money that people
are sp spent
are paid running development agencies
right
your average person in britain who's
being asked to give
and on average your average british
citizen would have had to give if you
look at the compare the amount of money
we were giving to the
uh working population about five hundred
dollars a year
towards this right so imagine maybe
you've got a lower income you're
giving an effect two three hundred
dollars a year towards this
it's very very difficult for you to
understand
why somebody running a big charity is
earning hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year because you think that this
is being done um
as a sort of voluntary charitable
activity you're imagining what's
happening in international development
in terms of you know what's happening in
your local community
somebody working on a very low income
out of a great sense of idealism
and suddenly you're having to confront
the fact that these are organizations
with contractors who are poverty experts
earning
fifteen hundred dollars a day doing
poverty alleviation in somebody else's
country right
um now let me just tie this back to to
human rights so we can now get into more
of a conversation um
fundamentally the question around human
rights is how on earth
do you as the united states or the
united kingdom or indeed anybody
develop country strategies how do you
decide
whether or not you are going to for
example give money to rwanda and
ethiopia why do i choose them
i choose them because they are amongst
the most brutal
authoritarian regimes in africa and they
are also the greatest development
success stories in africa right
they are the places that development
economists are really excited by they're
almost the only two countries in
in in africa which people really get
huge excited by because they've achieved
seven eight percent growth even nine ten
percent growth
um over the last decade or so
and and what sort of leverage do you
have because
somewhere implicit in this conversation
is an
idea that people have that you could
improve the human rights performance of
these countries
by using the carrot of development aid
as the way to do it
but in practice that almost never works
and i saw it and i'll finish with these
two examples i saw it in south sudan
where my colleague and friend mark
greene who was running us-8 when i was
running differed
went in to see salvakia so horrible
civil war happening in south sudan
and the president of south sudan
salvakir deeply implicated in incredible
brutal massacres in horror
and stealing our development persistence
so we'd send in food aid and it'd be
stolen at the borders and people being
gunned down in malacanang
and mark green said look if you continue
behaving like this
we will cut off the development program
and salvage here effectively shrugged
and said fine
you know you want to take the money away
that's your problem you want lots of
poor people to starve that's your
problem take the money i don't care
right and again in tanzania
uh manga fully president magnufully who
the great anti-coveted campaigner whose
anti-code campaign came to an
unfortunate end a week ago
um uh refused to take a call from the
u.s
secretary of state the u.s ambassador
refused to go and see him he declared
the u.s ambassador persona non grata
kicked him out
and the us government was effectively
forced to come back again into tanzania
a couple of years later with a billion
dollars worth
of development assistance to try to buy
their way back into the good graces of a
relatively small country in sub-saharan
africa
because the assumptions that the u.s and
the uk have about power that somehow
they can use
even rather large sums of money as ways
of changing the behavior of people in
these countries
completely underestimates uh
the power of nationalism state
sovereignty
the actual incentives of people who are
in political power in countries ranging
from myanmar through to tanzania
and really calls into question the
extent to which it is actually possible
you know even if it were desirable
actually possible to use development
assistance
as a leaver for transforming attitudes
to human rights okay
enough for me thank you rory uh so
rory just talked about some of the
limits of development aid as a carrot
or in fact saying it doesn't work um or
there are many examples of it not
working so i'm curious uh before
i ask some questions i have and get to
questions from our audience do any of
our panelists want to react to that or
react to anything else you heard
uh where you might be on the edge of
your seat and have something to say
otherwise we have some great questions
coming in but i wanted to give you all
an opportunity
okay so i'm gonna go ahead and ask
a question that sam posed
or or turn it into a question sam sam
basically said the question we're asking
today our human rights back on the
international aid agenda
might not be the framing he would use um
and that he's not quite sure we're
really on the brink of major change
i'm curious what do our other panelists
think is this is this a
critical turning point or or not
necessarily let
let me throw a second in and then come
to people um
it it seems to me that part of this
needs to be understood in terms of
um competition with china and in
particular in attempts by
president biden and johnson and others
to try to frame
democracy as an alternative to
authoritarian regimes and so
insofar as human rights gets back onto
the agenda i suspect a lot of it will be
through the prism
of trying to create a coalition of
inverted commons democracies
um in this new form of competition or
conflict with china
but again and i think i'd love to hear
from melissa on this
the experience of the cold war suggests
that
although you may talk about creating
democracies
as the alternative to your authoritarian
rivals in practice you end up with
cooperating with people who aren't
democracies at all
i'm glad we're returning to the topic of
china thoughts on that melissa
yeah i mean i think that it's um
it's sort of a matter of degree
in terms of like what you're doing and
what you can achieve and so i
you know i agree that there is no you
know like whether you're coming at it
from the side
of kind of the us or the soviet union
during the cold war there's not like
neither
kind of group has a great track record
of being able to
essentially like um force countries to
to take on their model whether you look
at the soviet union in afghanistan the
us and vietnam
um you know there's maybe some success
stories like panama
um comes to mind from the perspective of
the us but i think it just sort of like
it it depends on what you want to
achieve and i
i agree that if the goal is to you know
um
you you have some brutal dictator and
you think that with the carrot of this
development aid you're gonna
change his policies like that's just not
realistic and that's just not going to
happen
um but you know there have been like you
know a series of studies looking
um you know in conflict zones and
afghanistan or pakistan
the philippines um looking at the role
of the development aid programs and i'd
say the literature is kind of
like a little bit mixed um you know but
there's some evidence
um that the that these programs at least
it's going to depend on the details
but there can be success in terms of
giving people like an alternative
besides supporting the taliban or so i
think that when you think about things
on kind of like a more
um granular level um as opposed to
um you know looking at political change
at the national level that then there
can be kind of more
um more examples where things come sort
of closer
um closer to um achieving
what the objectives are but i i agree
that i don't think we really
know how this works we understand a lot
more
about what you would need to do in a
world without politics to alleviate
poverty than
how you actually um do that in a
political context where there's people
who
just don't care or actually benefit from
the fact
that lots of people are living in
poverty
thanks melissa and well put in terms of
how this works in a world without
politics versus a world with politics
which is part of the value in bringing
uh academics and practitioners together
sam i see you wanted to jump in
uh it's so interesting i just you know
i'm very averse to the general framing
that we're
we're entering a a new cold war with
china i think it's
you know disastrous that we're allowing
donald trump
uh to define you know our own
relationship to this coming year of
geopolitics not least since it seems
really hard to think about
the current chinese state as similar to
the soviet union
in its broader agenda i mean of course
it is a communist state formally
but it's not like the global peasantry
or its you know its leaders
is being set on fire by communism
or as a as an ideological matter or
by neo-confucianism or whatever you
think
china represents and you know we'd have
to get into
like really serious debates uh about
what china's
you know outward-facing politics really
are
um to figure out what kind of threat
they they pose unless by threat you mean
that they're getting really rich really
fast
of course it's absolutely true uh and
rory's right about this that
they're they're repressing at home and
i think human rights are of considerable
use and thinking about what kind of
china policy
uh western states ought to have you know
to to
get get the uyghurs some attention
although probably not much help
it's very different to suppose that the
rise of china
represents a kind of new era of
competition globally
where we have to like you know decide
which
despots were going to prop up uh
whether with melissa or you know on the
brink of
bombing a lot of peasants into you know
capitalism
that does it doesn't seem like we're
anywhere close to that situation
um and so you please sorry please just i
mean i
i i look i'm my sympathies are with you
on this but i think that
um one of the oddities
about the way that particularly
departments of defense think
is they like to have an enemy and when
they frame
strategic security policies they do
these things so britain for example has
just
published its integrated security review
and the whole review is about a shift to
the indo-pacific
and so effectively it's moving out of
them at least in africa or trying to
um and a loss of the framing around the
g10 meetings
uh are also around democracies
and in so far as um
we can read the tea leaves of the recent
lincoln meetings with the chinese this
is becoming more and more important so
i think it's possible for us to agree
with you so this may not be a very
sensible thing to do but i think
empirically there's a lot of evidence
that there's huge temptations from the
national security establishments
in europe and in the united states of
increasingly framing their whole
international policy over the next 20
years
oh there's no doubt about i mean i can
see that entirely
uh but that that they're not actually
the political leadership
uh they're supposed to be subordinate to
it uh but no you're of course you're
right that these forces are active
and you know the the the national
security expertise
quite far beyond militaries is always
seeking enemies as you say
um i think the real dilemma is how to
free development
uh assistance from that kind of
politicization but also recognize that
the track record is grim
for um linking it to a kind of
democratization and human rights
strategy first that it's
it's not clear that these western states
don't in the end often side with despots
uh for the wrong reasons but also when
they when they side against them they
don't make that much of a difference
so i'm not you know i'm i'm just kind of
suggesting that if we in if we
detach that discussion from the
geopolitics of
standing down china we might kind of you
know make a little more progress but of
course you're right that
we may not have a choice given that lots
of interests are leading us towards this
new cold war framing
let me just jump in with one question
i think which is on moving from thinking
about bilaterals to thinking about
multilateral institutions
um and maybe the when we think about the
human rights perhaps the one to really
bring on stage is to think about the
united nations
um i think in the 1990s
uh what we did see was the u.n played
quite an important role
in terms of human rights by by
entering the stage when a newly in
countries coming out of conflict were
writing constitutions
so we saw a lot of you and push that the
one that i'm the most familiar with is
on gender quotas
so i think in country after country the
u.n pushed very hard to have gender
quotas put in place for instance in
rwanda
and it was accepted by the countries at
that point in time because very often
women would say less implicated
in conflict and so um they were more
willing to
to have them be part of it and so you
know certainly
it's one reason why in rwanda now it's a
majority
you know female parliament and we can
debate whether or not had
it had a role but that that's one place
where i think the u.n which in many
other places
you know doesn't have much money or much
influence was able to
strategically make a difference by
entering on constitution
writing so i'd be curious if we sort of
see places where
um perhaps maybe less bilaterals but
more
multilaterals could enter i think the
flip side of the un is the world bank
which for the longest time said
it would not engage with politics or
governance it was very explicit about
it but seems to have more recently been
willing to start thinking about it
perhaps through a more
anodyne term like state capacity
you're absolutely right there's
something very interesting that you've
pointed out there in rwanda because it's
a paradox isn't that
on the one hand they've achieved these
remarkable statistics into
terms of female participation parliament
on the other hand it is an intense the
authoritarian regime
which has included you know
assassination of political opponents and
all forms of repression so
that i think this may be rather
interesting theme that could be pursued
if we had more time about
the ways in which uh conversations about
diversity and conversations about what
we traditionally call liberty
um may be heading in different
directions in other words that
it would be possible to create a regime
and indeed i think they're beginning to
emerge
which seem to
resemble our images of diversity
without bringing the kinds of benefits
um
in terms of liberty and maybe ultimately
in terms of stability and peace that you
would have anticipated
i'll just uh add on to that you know i i
think rohini's asked a really important
question
but there's there's a in a way a a a
a history to this present divergence
that rory notes i mean just to cite one
example
of the authoritarian feminism of someone
like
princess ashraf of iran before
her brother's government was was toppled
which which the the western powers
supported of course
and that was another example where um
there there was a lot of talk about the
regime's feminism
uh and and and she in particular talked
about a lot about it at
global u.n human rights conferences the
world over
notably in the tehran conference at
night in 1968
but of course that didn't mean that
uh the you know iranian regime was
bringing liberty uh generally and
of course it eventually paid the price
i want to bring in a few questions from
our audience and
um keep them coming although i know
we're running out of time but there's
some fantastic questions here and we're
kind of moving around geographically
in these questions but this is a
question related to
central america and migration so ellen
messer asks
uh president biden says that u.s and
central american countries
must address central american sources
root causes of migration which are
extreme poverty
and violence there can be no u.s
national security
democracy human rights and freedoms at
home until poverty eradication and human
rights uplift people's lives everywhere
can speakers comment on a possible human
rights agenda for central america
so uh any thoughts on that then we have
questions
moving us around other parts of the
world to follow but
i think like um i'll just bring in a
point that kind of like
indirectly addresses this um and that
like
um you know this conversation seems like
pretty
pessimistic but i think it's actually
just realistic
on you know reflecting all the
difficulties
of going you know into a foreign country
and changing the equilibrium there
you know whether it's eradicating
extreme poverty but also the politics of
it and
that ties in a lot and that's certainly
true in central america
um but it's also true that like we can
think about like
are there domestic policies that
would have a huge impact um on places
like central america
on the developing world because
ultimately like what we
like the world's like connected and so
like in the case of central america i
mean like one obvious thing
is the war on drugs and we know that
it's completely like
failed in the us i mean like it's not
that
like it had no effect essentially like
on
you know the number of americans that
have problems with drug addiction
um and just like fixing that own failed
policy at home even if we can never
convince the american public to care one
bit
about central america just coming up
with a more
effective you know strategy
like for drug addiction you know would
have an effect i know like a lot of the
damage is done and there's also you know
there's also other things that play just
a very weak state
um and that that like kind of wanders
into the realm of things that we don't
really know how
to how to fix um but
you know um just things like that or
another huge point for central america
and if we want to talk about extreme
poverty
is climate change and so um
when you look at predictions for like um
what the climate is going to look like
in 2100 central america looks like
uninhabitable virtually i mean because
it's already very hot and that's going
to just get very much more extreme and
this is another thing i've done work on
about how
the impacts of extreme temperature are
much more severe
on poor countries um and part of it's
because they're hot
but also just they have kind of less
coping strategies at hand
um and you know i think that there's
like also a growing sense that climate
change is bad for the us
there's bad for europe i mean look at
california being on fire so maybe like
you know like even if we think that um
that there's not a huge amount of hope
for these
um kind of um foreign aid like
development assistance objectives if
we're just like
more modest there but you realize just
by fixing some of the policy
like you know getting policies more
right like
and going back to the like the biden
thing about like well can this help the
middle class in america like
um you know maybe some of these policies
like
yes they can and they can be spun in
that way but like
they have the potential to have an
effect that is much kind of larger than
whatever
you know in the grand scheme of things
fairly measly like
you know development aid so i'm
certainly not saying to abandon
development
assistance or um you know the like these
objectives of like
you know state capacity as rohini said
which is kind of how it gets framed like
in the context of central america or
you know development assistance but i
think that you know like as we've talked
about they don't have a great track
record and maybe like another
perspective
on it is that by you know fixing some of
these problems at home
um we're less likely to just have this
collateral damage or go
and be you know propping up dictators
and doing these other things that have
horrible effects
sam i see you wanted to jump in quickly
yeah no i i think the question's really
well taken because
apart from the let's say difficult
optics that joe biden faces
to the extent he has to you know um
have exclusionary uh politics at the
border of any kind
um he has you know and and liberals
generally have a difficulty of figuring
out how to connect the short term in the
long term so in the short term
with folks at the border there is a
human rights obligation minimally to
hear
and grant you know legitimate asylum
claims
even when migrants are economic uh
migrants and converting their claims
into the
kind of claims that can be taken
seriously
but in the long term it's not clear to
me
that the global anti-poverty agenda is
ever going to by itself alleviate
the drivers of migration and this is an
opportunity for
me to introduce like the main theme of
my recent book which is a contrast
between
these ideas about sufficient provision
whether
generous or ungenerous and this very
different idea
of more egalitarian living standards
it seems like dubious to me that once a
peasant gets above a dollar and change a
day
he'll decide not to move to the united
states if he can get there
and so i totally agree with melissa
about the looming
climate refugee crisis but quite apart
from it
if we don't focus our development
thinking on
greater equalization over the long term
of standards of living we will have
economic migration for as long as we can
see and then the attendant border
politics that
you know are across mediterranean
politics that we've seen have roiled the
world in recent decades
i want to bring in one more question and
um
it has to do with china and i was hoping
to bring it in earlier but i think i'd
like to broaden the frame as rohini did
earlier
thinking not just in terms of bilaterals
but multilaterals
um and we'll we'll have a quick go
around on this question and then i want
to have time for closing thoughts but
um thomas kingston asks having worked in
human rights law in cambodia
and having witnessed their government's
shift from a pro-european
pro-us stance to a pro-china stance
it seems to me that there's a limitation
of how human rights promotion can be
achieved through aid
especially in less democratic systems
when china is offering support that
comes without moral
or democratic obligations how can this
be overcome or is it just going to
result in a bidding war
so i think this builds on some of what
we discussed earlier but what i
appreciate about this question
is it's from the perspective of
countries
receiving assistance and and i think you
see this playing out
in many countries in africa as well
receiving assistance from china
um but any quick thoughts in response to
that question because i wanted to bring
in a
perspective from the audience on china
so
very quickly i think the the big change
since the un intervention in cambodia
is the incredible shift in the status
prestige
power and weight of china it's the big
fact over the last 20 years i mean from
a british point of view one way of
thinking about it
is that um in 2005 the british economy
was larger than the chinese economy
and the chinese economy is now seven
times larger than the british economy so
that's happened just in
15 years the same relationship uh has
emerged throughout the world really and
therefore
it doesn't matter whether you're talking
about
cambodia or whether you're talking about
zimbabwe
the basic story of the weight and
prestige of
the united states and its allies seem to
have
in the 1990s has evaporated and been
replaced by that status of china
thanks rory sam i see you want to jump
in there yeah just briefly it's
we shouldn't forget that the
geopolitical competition is sometimes a
great boon to the world's peoples
especially when they can play
competing hegemons off against each
other so we
melissa's story is great but we
shouldn't think the alternative
is you know force and hearts and minds
which
anyway was never unconnected from force
in the vietnam case like the phoenix
program and things like that
um but the broader story of cold war
development is that
there are a lot of kanye actors across
the global south who understood that
they could play
rivals off against each other to get
more from each
a great example of that is in david
angerman our colleagues recent book the
price of eight about how
indian statesmen basically planners and
others were able to take a lot
from both americans and the soviet union
because they knew
that uh their generosity was was not
just
uh innocent but reflected these uh
competing uh
you know competition ideologies
sam actually just mentioned one of our
panelists from the first of our
yale development dialogue series so it
brings it full circle um we only have a
couple minutes left and i want to make
sure to go back to each of you
with any closing thoughts earlier i
think it was
melissa who said we're not being
pessimistic just realistic
but um i don't know if there's a chance
to end on a note of optimism
uh i i think what i'd love to hear from
each of you is
um kind of back to where we begin why
this question why now
and what do you hope to see so anything
more forward-looking um
who wants to jump in rory
okay i mean i i i'd say just closing
thoughts
first thing is that at the core of a lot
of what we're talking about is
basically modernization theory this idea
from the 1950s that there is somehow
some
natural relationship between being
prosperous
being free and being democratic and we
are
struggling now partly because of china
partly because of populism
with the possibility that those things
don't go as naturally together as we
assumed
um however um i would say if you want me
to end with a node of optimism and this
maybe touch someone this is saying
i have seen a lot of very good small
scale programs
on support human rights and i feel in
pakistan and bangladesh for example that
small amounts of money supporting civil
society organizations
some very very courageous civil society
organizations has been extraordinary and
the counterfactual
you know what would happen if there had
been no support whatsoever
the human rights campaign is working on
minority communities in pakistan
i think is very very worrying indeed so
i think it's
it's a very good thing for development
agencies to do i think it's always going
to be a very small part of their budget
because in fact
if what you're talking about is
supporting activists on the ground
that's not going to remotely compare
with the
you know 20 billion dollars that you're
putting into the the other stuff but i i
think there is still scope to do a lot
and i think we can continue to do it
when conditions allow
thanks rory i want to close with rohini
but first sam or melissa do either of
you want to jump in
any final thoughts in our we're at time
but i want to
make sure to bring you in if you have
something else i completely agree
with what was just said um so oftentimes
in this
in like development there's this big
debate between like
oh doing these like you know big picture
things that will like
you know like make a dramatic difference
you know the gp
and like on a big picture versus the
smaller scale programs
um where um it's just easier
to see success because the number of
things that need to change
to make a dramatic difference in kind of
levels of poverty are just huge and we
don't really have an understanding of
how
politics works or the economics works
and so it's not we should be asking
those questions i think they're
important questions
but it's easier to see and actually to
evaluate the successes
when you look at some of the smaller
scale um programs so i agree that like
for political reasons that's never going
to be the main thing
um but that that should be kind of a
central a central thing moving forward
just because we have
more hopes when we're making small
changes and we're trying to make small
changes that we know that that
that we're gonna see um effectiveness
there and so i think that you know in
addition to having these kind of
ambitious talks about how is everything
changing this new paradigm um
you know just just thinking about the
things that have worked even if they're
small scale
um and you know doing what we can to
advocate
for those and as i said also to you know
thinking about
you know trying to have more
appreciation for how you know there's
policies that can actually
benefit the the home countries that are
supporting this aid benefit
you know the median voter and um
also benefit um people elsewhere in the
world
thanks melissa sam final thoughts from
you sure well
you know there's always ground for
optimism they have to involve seizing
opportunities
and and i i'd go back to the very
beginning with
rohini and rory about the opportunity
that
is is open to us now because
elites in wealthy countries are
frightened
uh and they they've been they know
they've
been thrown out of power in some cases
and they're
they're eager to figure out what that
means um and
change their ways jake sullivan is a
great example who remarked in 2017
uh that he had the humility of the
defeated uh and
i think like lincoln uh sullivan others
are evolving in really interesting ways
the question is what they do next and i
think we should warn them against
a repeat of the cold war for
some of the reasons melissa mentioned
but also because it doesn't even seem to
make any sense
with the new adversary um
and instead push them in in ways that
will
will make the world's peoples better off
uh in us
in a series of ways rohini back to you
to close i i
thank you for putting this topic on our
agenda for the series i think it's been
fascinating what are your final thoughts
um i think i'll just echo what all the
panelists say maybe the one thing i
would add which is a bit
inward looking for the u.s that just
given the huge role that i would say
tech giants are playing now a lot of
what the us is going to decide to do
in terms of antitrust in terms of how to
um you know uh get them to
uh think about uses of data of when it's
going to be for surveillance when it's
going to be for transparency
i think it's going to be incredibly
important in a lot of
low-income countries but also in
countries like hong kong china
other places where you know what we're
seeing is that ability to
for civil society and others to protest
to push for human rights
depends a lot on how they are being able
to use social media right now for
coordinating protests
thank you rohini well i know we're over
time thank you all for bearing with us
um
i i'm really glad though that we were
able to go back and hear from each of
our panelists
on this very important topic um and i
think we we're emerging with more
questions that need to be answered
but we'll keep the conversation going um
we look forward to seeing all of you
in our next uh iteration of the l
development dialogue series
where again we're bringing together
historians and practitioners
for conversations on these complex
topics as they affect low and
middle-income countries i think this is
a great
example of why there's such value in
that framing so thank you to all of our
panelists
thank you to our attendees and we'll see
you next time
you